that dawn broke  here next to the munchelny village the  rain though due it was very pretty this  morning but the rain's due from about  10 o'clock this morning the winds  already starting to pick up it's going  to be the spring high tide  over this weekend and the locals are  preparing themselves for even more  misery the army is on standby the fire  service they're here hovercraft have  been brought in high-powered pumps to  try and get rid of some of this water  with that but with that springtide  coming and the rains coming as well  around about 10 o'clock this morning it  is going to be another miserable weekend  for the people here in somerset we're  here all day to update you on what's  going remember of course it's not just  this county but the rest of the country  likely to be affected all of those flood  alerts will be on sky news for ipads so  check that out if you are in any way  concerned about what might happen